each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
high-performance programming language
before Brad joined Cray he worked at he
was a student at university of
washington and did his PhD there he
worked on ZPL which if people know is a
data parallel programming language so
one that has had some sort of we
certainly looked at it and with that I'd
like to turn over to Brad I'm really
looking forward to hearing this talk
thanks very much all right so good
morning and thanks for coming as you
heard my name is Brad Chamberlain i work
at cray i'm gonna be talking to you
today about this language we're
developing called chapel which is as
david said a next-generation parallel
programming language and this is joint
work with our academic colleagues at
Caltech JPL i just get to be the one to
tell you about it today so let me start
out by telling you about the context for
this work this work is being done as
part of which what's called the HP CS
project which stands for high
productivity computing systems so the p
there has changed from performance which
is what it typically is in hpc to
productivity this is a program that
DARPA started a while back and we'll go
through the year 2010 the overall goal
of this program is to increase
productivity for high-end computing so
the observation is the time computing is
sort of frustrating and hard and what
can we be doing to make it easier and
this program defines the term
productivity to mean programmability
with performance which with portability
with robustness so these are sort of the
four prongs of productivity that the
program tries to address and people
participating this program we're
required to turn out a result which
would be revolutionary not just sort of
the next step of the product line they
had to sort of step off that
evolutionary scale and also has to be
marketable to users beyond just the
program sponsors so the goal here is to
generate something that will have wide
spread effect as opposed something that
just DARPA and other government agencies
will be interested in and nobody else
will be we're currently in the middle of
phase two of this program are actually
towards the end of Phase two this
program there are three vendors
participating at this point Cray IBM and
son
about to go through a Down select in the
summer of two thousand six to either one
or two teams and that those teams will
go on and build their systems for the
year 2010 I'll talk a little bit more
about that down select later on at the
end of the talk so crazed effort in this
hpcs program is called cascade that's
the name of the project and cascade is
essentially looking at parallel
computing systems all the way across the
system stack to see how they can be
changed to impact productivity this
includes new processor designs new
memory architectures network designs
operating systems runtime compilers
tools program environments and languages
languages is where chapel fits in and
chapel stands roughly for the Cascade
high productivity language that's what
you'll be hearing about today I'm not
really going to spend any time today
talking about the rest of the program
other than to just highlight a few of
the architectural features of the
Cascade machine that we're designing
because that will help you understand
some of the design decisions we've made
for the language so the Cascade machine
will have a global shared address space
the network is a high rate X HIBE and
with Network it adds processors which
can tolerate memory latency zuv remote
access ease either through vectors or
through multithreading and hardware and
we think of this machine is being
organized into locales and you can think
of a look how sort of processing
component with the memory that it can
access cheaply because it's nearby so
it's sort of the unit of locality within
the hardware so when I go out and give
talks about chapel one of the questions
you get a lot of hpc community which the
community has traditionally been burned
by languages in the past as well why you
bothering develop a new language why
waste your time and this slide has a
long answer most of which I've grayed
out the short answer is that we believe
the current parallel languages are
lacking and normally I would tell you
why and normally you'd be members of hpc
community so you'd sort of yet go yeah
yeah that's true but instead what I've
done is I've introduced a slight detour
here where I'm going to talk to you a
little bit about some of the parallel
programming models that are out there in
case you're not familiar with them and
then I'll come back to that slide and
we'll go through the great out topic
okay so this is my very quick
introduction to parallel programming
models then I'll talk to you about
Chapel a bit then if time permits we'll
go through a sample computation
chapel and then I have some wrap-up
slides at the end okay so parallel
programming models I'm only going to
talk about models at a very high level
and in particular talk about sort of
these three distinctions that I think of
in the chapel project we came up with
this term for fragmented programming
models these are models in which the
programmer basically writes code
thinking about their program on a
processor by processor basis so you're
writing code that says what should this
processor do and the idea being that
you'll have many of these programs
running which caused all of the
processors to sort of work together so
in doing this you're going to take your
data structures you're going to break
them up into little per processor pieces
and you're going to take your control
flow and break that up in little per
processor pieces as well one of the main
instances of this fragmented model which
is really the most common instance that
almost everyone uses today is called the
spm d model or single program multiple
data the idea here is you're going to
write one program and then just run
multiple copies of that program and to
make it do actually something
interesting those programs are
parametrized by what instance number you
are so you'll have branches on sort of
if I'm processor 0 processor 1 so on and
so forth so most of the parallel
language that people use today fit this
SPM d model that's the way people write
code in contrast with these fragmented
Ness PMD models we have a session of a
global view model this is a model in
which the programmer doesn't need to
break everything down into a processor
by processor basis they write things in
a more holistic fashion and it's the
compiler and the runtimes responsibility
to actually take that whole description
the problem and break it down into per
processor pieces and I should say that
while we think of the compiler in the
runtime is bearing most this
responsibility the programmer can have
hooks within the language to help guide
the compile on the run time to the
solution that they want so let me make
this a little bit more concrete except
that maybe I've turned off my remote or
maybe I did something else okay let's
take a very simple data parallel example
say we want to add 2,000 element vectors
and assign the result to a third
thousand element vector here I've
replaced the number thousand by six it
looks like so it fits on my slide in a
global view model you'd want to just say
okay I've got these two vectors they
have a thousand units I want to add them
together in a sign
in a fragmented model you would instead
take those vectors and break them up
into these per processor pieces in terms
of both the allocation and the control
so you're thinking in terms of those red
lines indicate processor boundaries
you're thinking about writing code that
specifies what happens within any two of
those red lines and so the code using a
pseudocode notation might look something
like this in the global view model I
have declared my problem size a thousand
and I've declared my arrays using that
global problem size of a thousand and
then why do my a eight over the
global problem size of a thousand that's
kind of intuitive and natural in the
fragmented model instead what I'm going
to do the changes are shown in blue is
I'm going to declare this variable local
end this is the number of elements that
each processor owns so that's going to
be computed by taking an and dividing by
the number of processors and then I
declare both my arrays and my loop in
terms of that local end rather than the
global n so this isn't this doesn't look
that big of a deal but this is about the
simplest parallel program you could
write the other thing to notice here is
that I've assumed that the n divides
evenly by the number of processors and
if in fact that weren't true or i want
didn't want to write that assumption
into the code I'd have to put in more
effort to write a more general version
of the code okay so again this is a
really simple program so i'll go
slightly more interesting one this is a
problem where i say apply a three-point
stencil to a vector so i'm going to
replace each interior element of the
orange vector down here with the average
of its two nearest neighbors from the
blue vector and so again in the global
view i want to think about it in this
sort of global terms in the fragmented
view again i'm going to chop those
vectors up into pro processor pieces but
this time because some of the data i
need to access is not local i'm going to
allocate additional storage to cash
non-local values on my processor and so
then I need to introduce communication
in order to update those cash values get
copies of what my neighboring processors
have and only at that point can I
actually do the computation itself
basically on each processor I'll then
replace orange elements with the average
of their two neighboring blue elements
okay so in terms of the code this has
more complexity as before I chop up my
problem size across the processors but
then I introduce some sort of
communication here which says well if I
have a right neighbor I need to exchange
a piece of data with it
and if I have a left neighbor I need to
exchange a piece of data with it and
this is the code that I've actually been
showing this talk for over a year a
friend of mine gave it version of this
talk recently and he found a bug in this
which in my mind is sort of shows how
the fragmented model is kind of
frustrating does anybody see it offhand
I know you haven't had much time to look
at this ok so the bug was this loop here
so I'm looping over I'm saying all
processors should loop over their local
elements doing this averaging step but
the problem is because of my global view
I don't want to do the two end points
I'm looping from 2 to n minus 1 rather
than 1 to N I have the same problem here
where the I need to do those global
boundaries here as well so what I needed
to do is put in some additional
variables which said well in this loop
what bound should I loop over and then
depending on whether or not I have a
right or left neighbor I have to adjust
those upper bounds and these are the
kind of details that the fragment model
just sort of forces on the program in
which drive you crazy very quickly this
is why we prefer a global view the other
thing to note here is that the
communication I've expressed here is
proportional to sort of the dimension of
the array you're operating on so here
because we're working on vectors we have
to communicate with two neighbors if you
work on 2d arrays and their distribute
in both dimensions you tend to have to
communicate with you aight nearest
neighbors in 3ds 27 so you sort of have
this explosion of communication you have
to express and do as you move to higher
dimensional arrays the one other thing I
wanted to say here was that I've
expressed all this communication in
terms of sends and receives which is a
two-sided message passing paradigm there
are many other paradigms the one could
use for this like co arrays or one side
of communication or shared memory with
synchronization and that's really not
the important thing the important thing
is that you as a programmer need to go
in and sort of manage this communication
by hand in these fragmented models ok so
just to blow this example up a little
bit more this is that example we just
saw replacing my little send/receive
pseudocode things with actual MPI calls
if you're not familiar with mpi this is
a library for message passing it's
pretty much the absolute dominant
programming model for high performance
computing right now like I would I don't
know the number but i would guess over
ninety-five percent of parallel codes
probably are written in MPI
and the main thing to note here is that
my sends and receives have kind of
blossomed into these calls with many
many arguments to specify where's the
data how much is it what type is it who
am i communicating with what's a unique
ID for this and then things like error
handling and stuff like that so this is
just to give you a flavor of what does
mpi programming look like for even this
very simple example all right let me
give you one other example of these
program models we've only looked at data
parallel examples so far but task rail
examples are also interesting so you
know we all learn the quicksort is a
divide-and-conquer algorithm it's sort
of should be trivially parallelizable so
globally I want to think about taking
this quick story breaking them into two
parallel tasks each which is broken into
two parallel tasks and so on and so
forth in a fragmented model I would
again need to decompose that across
processor somehow so here I've drawn red
lines again to indicate processor
boundaries they're being idea being that
one processor will handle sort of all of
the sorting work in any one of those
areas and if we look at the code for
this again in the global view I'd like
to sort of not worry about the process
so much so I'll say something like
compute a pivot and then in parallel do
these two quicksort stages that's what
that Co begin terminology means in the
fragmented model instead I have to again
sort of think about it from one
processors point of view so I sort of
have this recursion tree which is
overlaid on top of my processors and I
need to say well if I have a parent in
that tree let's receive some work to do
from them and then if I have a child i'm
going to compute a pivots and have to
work to my child do the other half
myself if I don't have a child i'm just
going to do all the sorting myself then
if i have a child i'm going to receive
their result back from them and if i
have a parent i'll send the global
result back to them so again there's
sort of a more work to be done here and
more obfuscation the algorithm in the
fragmented model okay so here's a quick
summary at least showing the biases that
I've just sort of shown to you when you
use these fragmented models you tend to
obfuscate the algorithms you're trying
to write by putting lots and lots of per
processor management detail right in
line with the computation now if you're
a scientific computing type of person
you've got a problem you want to solve
an algorithm you want to write and all
of these little details sort of make
working on that problem working the
algorithm much more
cated because the parallelism for you is
more of an acceleration mechanism it's
not sort of what you're getting paid to
do necessarily these models tend to also
require you to write your code with the
spm d model in mind and frankly provide
only a really blunt means of describing
both parallel ism and distributed data
structures which is well the parallelism
is these programs running and the
distributed data structures are whatever
data they allocate what I've done here
at the bottom is list a bunch of
parallel mostly parallel programming
systems and broken them into roughly
fragmented versus global view languages
the main thing to note here is that
almost all of the language that are
commonly used today or in this
fragmented model this is because they're
easy to compile frankly but it's
unfortunate because if you want to be
productive you'd really rather have more
of a global c language and there have
been global view languages in the past
hpf was a very notorious 1z PL the one
you heard I worked on at University of
Washington sigh Celyn Nestle which were
some functional languages Cray had a
dialect of MTA sorry a dialect of seeing
Fortran for their multithreading
architecture which also had this global
view nature and the point is that none
of these are really sort of escaped
being I guess research languages or
academic languages they haven't ever
made it into the mainstream with the
exception of hpf which did but faltered
and sort of is what why a lot of people
are grumpy about languages in our
community today
okay so back to this why develop a new
language as I said we believe current
parallel languages are laughing in
general the biggest thing for me is that
in general they tend to require this
fragmentation of data structures and
control structures and in doing that you
fail to cleanly isolate your computation
from various changes that you might want
to make up to it over time such as how
do you want to think of your virtual
processors as being arranged how do you
want to decompose data across those
processors how do you want to
communicate between those processors
what kind of data structures in memory
layout you want to use typically anytime
you change these things your program has
to change in major ways because even
better these details sort of throughout
the structure of the program some other
things which haven't come up in the past
slides most of the models we have today
tend to support only a single type of
parallelism well either data parallelism
or cast pearls and but not both usually
the other looks weird in any given
language they tend to fail to support a
composition of parallelism so you
typically have a single level of
parallelism and then you're sort of out
of luck if you have more parallel work
you want to do with in there they tend
to have very few data abstractions
things like distributed sparse arrays
graphs or hash tables these are things
that scientific the side of the
community wants to use all the time and
yet they always have to grow them
themselves by hand and in addition
there's just a lack of Brad sorry broad
market language features things that
young students coming out of school are
used to in language like Java and MATLAB
but then they're thrust into sort of
this fortran plus MPI or c plus MPI
world and they just think they've been
you know thrown back to the Stone Age
basically all right so those are our
reasons for doing chapel let me now tell
you a little bit about chapel yeah brief
summary of why the other languages and
the global view folder
yeah so I sort of skipped over up mp
OpenMP is actually a system which is
still in use today but it tends to
assume that you have shared memory
between all of your processing elements
and so what's been found in practice is
that OpenMP is good for talking about
sort of nodes of sort of sort of a say a
4 processor cluster or something like
that for those 4 processor nodes but not
so good across the cluster itself so an
SGI shared memory machine is one of the
few places you'll see openmp sort of
scaling to hundreds of thousands of
processors high performance for tree and
depending on who you talk to so high
performance Fortran was this really
large effort academia and the government
really threw a lot of weight behind this
corporation spent a lot of time on it
and why it faltered depends a lot on who
you talk to in grad school I used to
argue a lot that it faltered because it
didn't have a good performance model so
you as a programmer wrote code and the
language and the give you no guarantees
as to how that was going to be
implemented so you're sort of casting
your hope to the wind and then maybe you
got something working well with one
capallo you went to another compiler and
maybe it did something completely
different other people will argue that
it failed because it was called high
performance and when it version 1 point
0 shipped the performance wasn't that
good and people just immediately said oh
well forget that and didn't have the
patience to wait for it to mature others
would say that it didn't go far enough
in providing abstractions it had a few
abstractions but not so much that you
could do sort of for example sparse
distributed codes very easily and things
like that and therefore it was only it
wasn't it was to incremental essentially
ZPL I'm biased on and probably not the
right person to ask but in ZPL we never
really sort of broke out of an academic
setting we sort of did really nice
academic work we weren't sort of maybe
as entrepreneurial as other groups and
we're also dealing with the fact that
everyone was disgruntled about hpf and
so well I think we did nice work we
never sort of made it into a product or
had collaborations with the vendor or
anything like that so remains sort of an
academic work with functional languages
I think part of what was working against
them is just that they were functional
by nature you're trying to sell to an
industry that's very imperative ly based
Cray mtcn Fortran is great but it
depended very much on the Cray MTA
architecture Matlaba have up here
because a lot of people in this
community really want a parallel matlab
and i think one of the things they like
about it is that they don't have to
think about processors well there's a
bunch of language of course they don't
have to you could also put java and
seeing things like that there so that's
why I think I mean it's different for
every language colleagues where would
you put Google's MapReduce on the space
would you say it's not it's not a
language it's a shell or something would
you say that it's functional when
therefore you can sell into an
imperative thing or so I've been MIT I'm
not f naira it's a very special purpose
for later yeah I'm you can do
so it's just our school planes would you
call it global view like it does it
abstract the processor space away from
the sort of thing you're trying to
scribe the rights of maps reduce
operations over distributed data struct
over
yes that would make it i would say
now
here
yes so xn I should say that the other
two vendors are also developing
languages IBM's is called x10 Sons is
called fortress x 10 tries to straddle
the space in an interesting way x10 has
this notion of a place which you can
think of as being like our locale it's
sort of an area where you can do
computation to have some local memory
and when I read x10 a lot of what I see
looks very fragmented in nature you sort
of write code for these places and the
places communicate with each other using
these a synchro authorization operations
which are kind of like message passing
and that has a very fragmented feel to
it but in some of the talks I've heard
IBM talk about well but you could write
code that's just one place and written
for one place and then spread that place
across multiple processors and so the
implication there is well you could use
it in a global view mode where you sort
of only talk about one place and rely on
the compiler I guess to sort of spread
it across multiple physical processors
for me though that's not very compelling
I mean they obviously built a lot into
the language assuming you're going to
use this fragmented mode so I'm guessing
that the global view mode is not going
to be as good performance and there's
something else for example the idea I
don't think they're there yet but it's a
single locale or is it a small place
right so they would run a single place
on all 130,000 process or the biggest
pushing that would be but but they're
really trying to do is model them work
for flustered as piece which is what IBM
seats as their future so I think you'll
see you know something more like a
thousand sixteen processor thing with
the global view within the 16 processor
thing but explicit representation among
the DSPs yeah a lot of people do this
today with mpi and across meant okay
yeah me the problem with this is that
they sort of sell it as though yeah you
can do one place for multiple places but
it's not as though there's a gentle ramp
in making that transition it's like once
you decide you're gonna break up your
one place I suspect there's a lot of
work there and so to me that that isn't
sort of the best cell but yeah so
they're trying to kind of play both
games I would say
any other questions okay so let's talk
about Chapel a little bit
so Chapel as I said stands for the
Cascade high productivity language the
overall goal and I'll attribute this to
my ex-manager Wendy who's sitting in the
audience is to solve the parallel
programming problem and i should say in
saying that this is our goal that's not
to say we necessarily believe we're
going to do it but it's what we're
setting out to do wendy has given me
many many hours of grief over the school
so I had to keep it up here just for her
what I think about it is meaning is we
want to be able to simplify the creation
of parallel programs you should be able
to sit down at a parallel machine and
get a code up and running pretty quickly
it shouldn't be sort of this day's long
process just to get your first program
that runs across multiple processors or
uses the memory of multiple processors
up and running then what you want to be
able to do is take that code be written
pretty quickly and be able to evolve it
into more of a performance oriented code
more of a production Greg code without
completely abandoning the language
without completing completely rewriting
everything from scratch and the third
goal say here is to emphasize generality
so what a lot of languages do including
zpl the one I worked on in graduate
school it's a sort of carve off well
this is the area we're going to attack
and once you want to do something
outside that area you're kind of stuck
and so in designing Chapel we've
designed it very much to be a very
general parallel language they're
forming language technologies which have
motivated our design and I'm going to
use these sort of structure the way I
talk about most of the features in the
language the first is multi-threaded
parallel programming and I'll spend the
most time on this one the second is
locality where programming so being
aware of where things are on the machine
the third is object-oriented programming
and the fourth is generic programming
and type inference and I'll spend more
time on the earlier topics and less than
the later ones partially to reflect my
own interests and well I guess all only
to reflect my so first of all
multi-threaded parallel programming when
you think about this you should think of
this in terms of supporting language
concepts which virtualize threads so we
don't want you to have to go out and
write a bunch of sort of fork off the
thread and then join back together with
that thread rather we'd like to supply a
number of higher-level concepts which
result in multi-threaded execution where
use the user aren't explicitly naming
and talking about threads
so we have abstractions here to do this
both for data and task pearls and I'll
talk about these in much more length on
on the next few slides in addition as I
said we want to be able to compose
parallelism so you should be able to do
parallel work within another piece of
parallel work rather than having only a
single level of parallelism and we want
to support this global view of
computations and data structures which I
just talked about in length ok so let's
talk about data parallelism first
domains are sort of one of the key
concepts here for data parallelism and
you can think of a domain is essentially
a language concept a first class
language concept which represents an
index set ok a set of indices and you
can think of this as sort of something
which can specify the size and shape of
a raise typically in our languages
arrays and their index sets are sort of
all declared together here we've
factored the index set part away from
the array to talk about it separately
and I'll show more examples this on
subsequent slides these domains support
both sequential and parallel iteration
and they could potentially be decomposed
across locales so you can have a single
array or domain that's distributed
across multiple processors essentially
i'll talk about 3 million classes of
domains today the first start with medic
domains these are like the arrays your
most used to probably the indices are
cartesian tuples like rows and columns
and things like that so these tend to
represent rectilinear multi-dimensional
data spaces and they can be strutted in
any dimension or sparse in any dimension
the second type of domain is an
indefinite domain these are domains in
which the indices are essentially hash
keys so you can index into the array
using strings or object references or
things like that you can think of these
as being like associative arrays
essentially or hash tables third class
of domains are opaque domains and these
are ones in which the indices are
anonymous so you can think of this is
you've got a bunch of indices floating
out in space you don't have any
particularly good names for them based
on your problem that you're trying to
express so therefore they just sort of
anonymous and you can think of this as
being useful for describing sets or
graph based computation essentially
where there's not sort of this rigid
structure
as I said domains are chapels
fundamental concept for data parallelism
and if you're familiar with the CPI
language a lot of these domain concepts
come out of the region concept that
existed in in that language so here's a
really really simple domain declaration
I declare a couple of integers Eminem to
be four and eight and i declare this
domain D which I say is a
two-dimensional domain which puts it
into the arithmetic domain class and I
say that it goes from 1 to M + 1 to n so
that gives me this little four by eight
set of indices and again this looks a
lot like an array but it's not really an
array it's just sort of the indices
which you might use to describe an array
I can declare a second domain here
called D inner I declare this to
actually be rather than a
two-dimensional domain I say it's a
subdomain of d what that means is that
all of its indices are also going to be
indices of D and I say that it's going
to be from 2 to n minus 1 and 2 10 minus
1 so that gives me sort of the indices
there in the inner portion of date now
having created these domains I can use
them for a bunch of different things
first of all I'm going to use them to
declare arrays so at the top there I
declare arrays a and B which I say or
their size and shape are defined by
domain D and for every indexing domain D
I'd like to allocate a floating point
value so this gives me these four by
eight arrays of floating point values
you can use domains to do subah right
references sort of a rich slicing
notation so i can say a sub dnr equals B
sub B enter that takes the slices of a
and B which are described by the D inner
domain and assigns those leaving the
boundaries untouched I can also do
sequential and parallel iteration using
four and for all loops I guess I do have
to use the pointer sorry or no I can
stand over here or will the camera hit
me
I should use the point rats I have no
I've no steadiness in my hand okay so
sequential iteration says for all
indices I comma J indie inner do
something with a IJ for example so
that's just going to iterate over the
indices in the inner portion in
sequential order parallel duration is
similar for all I J and D enter do
something with a of IJ and i should say
the two forms i have here one just sort
of decomposes the indices into integers
essentially and the other one keeps it
as one tuple so we support tuples
language this is just to Polly indexing
of that array so the parallel version I
just replaced the floor with the frawl
or there's also an express expression
level peril iteration here which just
use a different syntax but is the same
thing in an expression context last use
of domains will talk about here is for a
reallocation if you reassign the index
set that a domain represents that
results in a reallocation of the arrays
that are declared over that domain so
here for example I'm doubling the size
of D in each dimension and that's going
to cause a and B to be reallocated to be
twice as being in each dimension as well
now this example may seem a little bit
funny and it probably is you may not
double the size of your two-dimensional
arrays very often but one of the places
where I think this has real good
application is in the case of sparse
domains wherever time you're sparse
computation may fill in you're going to
want to add in more indices over time
and have ideally have your race sort of
track those new indices rather than
having to go and reallocate everything
by hand okay so some other arithmetic
domains this first one d2 is actually
the same domain but declared using to a
tuple style notation and this is of
interest to me because I think writing
rank independent codes seems to be kind
of a pet project of mine and so this
would be a slightly more rank
independent way of writing this the
second one is a striated domain where I
take D and I stride it by two in the
first dimension and three in the second
dimension that'll still result in a
dense allocation but logically it allows
me to index into things in a strata
manner and last one is a sparse domain
where I again take a subset of D defined
by some index list and basically just
capture an arbitrary smart subset of
indices from d
one of the things I think is really
interesting about these domains is you
can think of there as being this
hierarchy of domains much as there's a
class hierarchy no object oriented
languages so if you've been following
the declarations I've been doing I said
the D&D two are both two-dimensional
domains then I'm ad enter and my stride
a domain and my sparse domain I'll be
sub domains of D and what that says
again is that each of these subdomains
contains indices that are only contained
within the parent domain there's also
this set of index types in language so
an index to for example it's just a two
dimensional index a row column or
something of that sort and then when I
say something like index of D that says
well this if I declare variable it's an
index of d this isn't just a two
dimensional index it's also an index
that happens to be in the d domain so
the nice thing here is that when you
have an expression like this fra loop
for all IJ and be enter what the
compiler is going to do is say well I
jay is an index of the DN or domain
because that's what I'm iterating over
and then when I use it daily Lex into a
which was defined over D I can say oh
well this index of the DNR domain that's
a subset of the indices within the D
domain and index within the D domain is
that's the domain we declared a over so
by definition this is going to be in
bounds I don't have to do any runtime
bounds checking in order to make sure
that's legal and I find this really
attractive both as a compiler writer in
terms of doing bounce checking
optimizations and as a programmer who
likes to write sort of code that's
descriptive it's sort of nice to say
this thing is guaranteed to be an index
of d as opposed just a general two
dimensional index alright so moving on
out of the arithmetic domains indefinite
domains with these ones that are kind of
have this hash table or dictionary type
of functionality here I declare a domain
called people this is a domain over
strings and then I declare two arrays
over it age which is an array / people
of integers and birth date which is nori
over people of strings and I can say
things like the age of John is 60 and
the birthdate of John is December 11th
1943 and this will cause that data to be
stored into the age and birthday to
raise I can think compete over these
just as I could the arithmetic domains
se4all person in people if the birthday
the person is today then the age of the
person plus equals one and as before
sort of the picture is that you've got
this domain which is just the
set of indices which are used to
describe this data structure and then
arrays which follow that domain in terms
of their size and shape and the third
category of domain is these are pake
domains again these you use to describe
set or graph based data structures and
so I say for example give me an opaque
domain name vertices and then because
these have these anonymous indices I can
just sit the way you get them because
you don't have a way of really naming
them as you say give me a new index in
the vertices domain so I've done this
five times here i end up with five
indices again if I declare a raise over
the this indefinite domain I end up with
a data element / / index here so I sort
of have these five floating-point values
floating out in space for each of my two
arrays there this is kind of an abstract
example let me make a slightly more
concrete one let's say I were to declare
to raise left and right which were
raised over my vertices we're at each
element I storing index into that vertex
domain I also store a variable root
which is an index into the vertex domain
and then i can write code like root it
gets new vertex and left or it gets a
new vertex and so on and so forth and
conceptual e what i'm doing is building
up this binary tree here and the code
sort of reflects that what's really
going on is that I've declared this
domain of vertices and I have these two
arrays left and right which are tracking
the domain is it changes on I've
basically set these up the store indices
back into the domain so in a sense you
can think of it as almost being like a
pointer based data structure I think the
user is probably going to tend to think
of it more in this conceptual model then
in this model
okay so that was a bunch of stuff on
domains and data parallelism moving out
into the task parallelism features
language we have a notion of co begins
in language this is a way of asserting
that two statements may be run in
parallel so we actually saw this in the
pseudocode for my quicksort before where
you compute a pivot then you say these
two quicksort calls can actually happen
completely in parallel they don't need
to be two instances the same task you
could also do compute a skank p task B
where those are very different things in
parallel we have notion language of
atomic sections this is a way of saying
that all of this code should execute as
though it was done at the same time
simultaneously with respect to any other
threads view of it so here for example I
have a doubly linked list insertion
that's something you don't want someone
coming in part way through and mucking
with the same pointers so we wrap it
with an atomic section to say all four
of these assignments should happen as
though they happen simultaneously and
the last feature I'm going to briefly
mention here today is notion of
synchronization and single assignment
variables these are variables which have
various semantics as to whether they can
be read or written and they typically
have a notion of being sort of full or
empty so if something's empty you can't
read it once you store into it that sets
at the full depending on how you set it
up someone else may or may not be able
to rewrite into it until it's been
emptied again this is very similar to a
concept that was in the Cray MTA
dialects of seeing Fortran and we're
taking those ideas and putting them into
chapel as well and this would be the
main way that when you setup tasks using
these code begins that you would have
them synchronize with one another
restricting the variables i can touch
when i do something like home again that
is good question so currently there's
not currently within the co begin you
can do pretty much anything so you can
do race conditions you can you can hurt
yourself yet and that's kind of by
design there's the sense that if once
you start putting restrictions on things
there may be things you can't write or
can't write as easily so we've taken the
approach of what letting people shoot
themselves in the foot but there is for
this concern that well is that really
going to make people more productive and
you might imagine the coping in which
you sort of say well this branch can
only touch these variable different cups
these variables and assert some sort of
safety that they're not going to hear
with each other I think that remains to
be seen whether we end up doing
something more along those lines it is
said about using this type system
it's even deeper something is constitute
modifiable life right we haven't done
anything along those lines yet but I
think that you can imagine certainly
introducing something like that what
this might make things much more
tractable Microsoft recent umbrage did
some nice work on atomic sections in
Haskell which use the type system to
sort of prove whether or not things to
go into an atomic clock were needed to
be accessed in an atomic clock I think
that was really attractive work as well
of it yeah I think one of the really
interesting open questions here is if
you have atomic and the functional
language like Haskell or single
assignment and declared properly right
is that enough you know is that is that
all you need or do you need more
stuffing because if that's all you need
the composability story looks pretty
good so you know if you start adding
locks or other things it gets a little
carrier right so it's a really good
question i think one of that
happens in four years an atomic section
and inside of it you make references are
stores to sync and single assignment
variables as the essence of atomic is
this sort of like transaction that
either happens all or none right and how
do you roll back a single assignment
I suppose you don't hit that single
Simon until after you leave the atomic
clock so X so anybody who's trying to
look at state has to block until
right so it's okay I mean the way these
for my clocks tend to be right so if you
spend to be appointed you do the
modifications sort of off on side data
structures and then at the end you see
can i swap all this state in and has
nothing I've read changed I imagine you
could do the same thing with single
assignment variables although after mate
I have a thought variant in fact they
have to be atomic being sociable with
Tommy maybe I have to get I fine not
bother myself Esther yes we as it
evolves yeah
so so one of the issues with strands
software transactional memory is always
that this question at what happens when
you do things like system cop do
disallow then he said what its semantics
I promised David I wouldn't throw
questions at him so David Callahan is
was one of our text line McAndrews ya
know you can do it I'm tempted to do it
I guess I don't know it seems though you
would probably want to restrict system
calls from being Atomics because the
fact that you can't really do them on
the side and in fact I know the hospital
work they did what did things like that
and also sort of juilliard about what
you can do with exceptions with an
atomic one I guess in my stammering what
I'm saying is I'm not the expert the
parallel features in the language and so
I don't know offhand sort of what the
exact restrictive deep this is the
solution in
in the in the Haskell framework it's
very elegant basically any system called
muniz an i/o and reference and that
can't be an argument to be to the that
turns transactional things entire things
so it's a kind of a cool way to do it
you just just say no it's my way to go
right right right there's some others
you could do but but but the things that
are pointed out in that paper in the
peapod paper need to be watched
carefully it's a nice solution to that
problem and you have to come up with one
least as good I think if you're gonna do
that my gut reaction of these kind of
questions is to just allow things that
are going to be extremely hard to sort
of do right or do efficient lights but
sort of disallowing the system calls
might be better than sort of allowing
them and then going to great lengths in
order to sort of make them all work but
that's just sort of a gut reaction I
don't know if all my team members would
agree with me on that okay so moving on
to the second theme of language locality
where programming this is this idea that
we sort of want to know where data is
and where computation takes place I
mentioned at the top of the talk that in
the architecture we have this notion of
a locale which is sort of a unit of
machine storage and processing there's
also that notion in the language as well
there's an opaque type called locale
which allows the programmer to refer to
the processing elements in the system
essentially so as a user of the language
when you start executing your program
you can specify the number of locales
you want to run out on the command line
so for example here i'm running a
program with eight locales whenever you
start up your program you're going to
have a built-in array of locales that's
provided for you by the language which
is essentially just sort of those eight
look in this example those eight locales
that you started running on and that
gives you sort of this seed to talk
about the processing resources but then
you can take those locales and put them
into different data structures that sort
of match your way of thinking about them
better so for example if you want to
think of those eight locales as being
sort of a two-dimensional two-by-four
set of locales then you can take that
array of locales and reshape it to be
this two-dimensional array of locales
that fits the way you want to think
about them or you could also take them
in carve them into two separate chunks
and say well I'd like sort of this the
set of two locales to work on
cascais and the set of six locales work
on task B I'd like to sort of separate
them into two rays of locales not Manor
example is there any semantics that
suggested the two over the to look out
that don't overlap know so you could
actually have one look how to belong to
both of these groups if you want okay
you can imagine that if you could prove
that two arrays locales had we're
disjoint but that might be really
beneficial information from sort of an
implementation optimization point of
view but language doesn't restrict you
from including the same ocala multiple
our execution model here is going to be
multi-threaded so you should think of
each those locales is having multiple
threads of control so the fact that a
locale belongs to two of these sets
shouldn't be worse because it can just
be running threads from either one of
those tasks for example so in some sense
you're moving away from this global view
that you were promoting before that's
right so there is this tension between
you want the global view for convenience
but at some point you may want to start
talking about processors or locales in
order to start optimizing for
performance more and so the question is
how do you do that in a way that allows
you to sort of gradually ramp from sort
of a pure global view where you're not
concerned about locales at all to sort
of a mixed mode where you're writing the
liberal view but you're still thinking
about we're killing the Pilar how to map
it to processors will see that in the
next slide to sort of a purely
fragmented model where you're really
programming sort of processor by
processor and our goal is to stay in
those top two categories as much as
possible and force you to fall back to
the third category only when absolutely
necessary if possible to have this be a
logical concept where you have one level
where you just define a bunch of look
house and then the second sort of
structure we figure out the mapping
between those locales the actual
hardware right so you talking about
rather than having sort of one-to-one
correspondence between is look how
hardware researchers have multiple
virtual software lapels mapped into one
hardware locale you certainly could do
that set of hardware locales for a set
of hardware look house well as
simple-minded excited about taking
taking a database partitioning it right
into end parts and then you just say
okay it's partitioned the map into the
processors modulo the number of physical
processors right
this question of mapping virtual look
out the physical locales is an
interesting one I don't think we're
opposed in language to having multiple
of the software Kyle's mapping to a
single hardware locale in my use I tend
to think of them one to one because I
get uncomfortable too much
virtualization but I I don't think
there's anything currently in language
spec or in the implantation which would
prevent you from doing that I guess is
how I would address that yeah so I get
two levels of locality essentially local
and remote yes
more than that yeah you can even imagine
doing that on current clusters where you
have sort of processors that are near
each other and farther from each other
and I've sort of wondered about whether
you could have sort of an array of array
of locales where sort of the first level
of the array meant it was more distant
at the second level meant they were more
closed for now that we're sort of only
working about worrying about remote
versus local but I think you're right
that that would be an interesting thing
to pursue when those architecture well I
guess they're already prevalent when you
start caring about that more now is no
way a process it's an address space it's
a neighborhood think of it that way so
if many-core gives you one neighborhood
/ die they're fine it's only when you
have internal locality on ship or
something like also but we gets to be
seen left leg absolutely we typically
wouldn't take one of these locales and
break it across sort of prosperous that
were reasonably distance so we wouldn't
sort of do the IBM thing of having one
look how that stands whole machine for
example
okay so a little bit about how we use
these locales the first is that locales
can be used to distribute domains so in
this example I've taken the same domain
declaration that we saw before for
domain D and i've added in this
additional information which says
distribute this in a block to manner to
conquer it which is all my
two-dimensional locale view there so
what this means is block 2 is for
example maybe a built-in library
distribution and it says to block both
dimensions of the domain so I sort of
end up with this eight look how
partitioning here and what that means is
each each locale is going to own that
piece of the domain in addition this
implies partitioning of the arrays that
were declared in terms of that locale
these distributions on these domains
specify not only a mapping of indices to
look house but we also think of them as
specifying how each locale should store
its indices locally and how it should
sorts array elements locally so you can
imagine for example for a sparse domain
that the distribution would specify
whether local to each locale this farce
indices were stored using compressed
sparse rose storage or some other sparse
storage format distributions language
are implemented as a class hierarchy and
you can think of it as chapel abiding a
number of standard distributions as part
of a class library essentially but users
can also write their own either from
scratch or by subclassing off that class
hierarchy and making modifications for
example to the standard block to fit
some particular feature of their
algorithm I should say that these user
defined data distributions I think are
one of our biggest research challenges
other languages have typically built in
a fixed number of distributions and if
it didn't suit your needs your kind of
out of luck we really want to make it
users able to write their own
distributions but this is a really hard
challenge without sacrificing
performance in a big way so we also use
locales to distribute computation this
is typically done with the on keyword
and we can say things like in this coby
ginn that I had before I've now appended
the work with this on indicator which
says compute task a on the task a
locales and compute task be on the task
B locales that's just an indicator of
where those computations should run you
can also use on in more of a data-driven
manner so here I've actually referenced
locales with the on clause you can also
reference just
data item and it says run it on
whichever locale owns that data item so
here I'm doing some weird assignment
from bead a using some weird indexing
scheme and I'm saying do this on the low
caledones the B element so for example
if I was computing this B element
assigned to that a element the locale
which is going to perform this
computation is the one that owns the B
element or F in this distribution okay
the third theme in language when I'm not
going to spend very much time on is
object-oriented programming I'm probably
preaching more to the choir here than I
am when I'm talking to the HPC community
object-oriented programming has
obviously proven to be very good in
helping to manage program complexity
it's wave encapsulating data and code
thats related to one another facilitates
reuse and separates common interfaces
from specific implementations in Chapel
we have two nisshin's of objects both
sort of what I'd call a traditional or
reference based object like in Java
where you pass and assign things by
reference as well as value classes where
you pass and assign things more x value
or by name in designing chapel we've
tried very hard not to make it a pure
object-oriented language the couple of
reasons for this one is sort of the
performance of sort of a very pure
object or in language where integers are
classes for example and the second is
that we want to make this language very
accessible to sort of the traditional
HPC community who uses predominantly
sort of see in Fortran still we'd like
you to be able to use chapel without
sort of for a lot of them you tell them
it's not different language and they say
oh well you know that's for young kids
and I don't know how to do all that and
I've you know I think about things
completely differently if I want to do
that and we'd like you to sort be able
to use this an imperative style if
that's your preference but also to be
able use an object or in style if if
that's your preference the one exception
to this is that several of the more
advanced language features we tend to
express using classes so if you want to
write your own data distribution for a
domain for example as I said before we
represent that using a class hierarchy
because that's a really nice way to say
here the interfaces that you need to
define and also to get some reuse so if
you were a fortran 77 programmer who
wanted to write your own data
distribution at that point you might
need to bite the bullet and at least
learn how to fill out sort of a very
specific class template
yes question there certain tends to be
more of an emphasis on dynamic memory
allocation you know objects be kind of
things in the heat and and then you know
once you have all these objects of the
heap in a global heap you have this
issue of sharing you know that you know
a particular object and the heat you
know who who can modify who owns it you
know and it doesn't seem like it
mechanisms that allow those objects to
be partitioned granny you know the
arrays can be pretty sure buddy right
say much about 40 tioning yeah so if you
just have a bunch of objects kind of
floating out in space then by and large
there's no way to talk about
partitioning them as an aggregate I mean
you could steer the allocation of each
one by saying on this locale new object
or things like that but that's obviously
pretty low level in and frustrating I
think if you really wanted to work with
the large collection of objects you
probably would create an array of those
objects such as for example the opaque
domain and array concept where you have
sort of these objects floating around in
space or maybe even specify
relationships between them so you would
imagine for example that a a
distribution on an opaque domain would
be more like a graph partitioning
algorithm and it might say okay well
I've built in some knowledge about sort
of what the semantics my objects are and
how they're interrelated from one
another and while I might like to think
of them as just this cloud of objects if
I went to the trouble of saying it's an
opaque array of objects then I sort of
have this ability to also talk about
their aggregate distribution that's kind
of the way I would imagine something
like that working in the language
it seems like it'd be very hard to do
any kind of static analysis to determine
whether a particular object can only be
modified by dick on noogler locale yeah
that's definitely true so currently I
would love for someone here to say this
is not a problem so currently in the
language spec currently in language spec
we have a notion of garbage collection
being one of the features language
primarily because of this kind of
problem you know it gets really hard to
manage sort of which those objects have
been allocated where of reference has
been captured things like that and so
also garbage collection is obviously
shown to be incredibly productive in the
central computing world so we have this
notion of garbage collection as a
featured language yet it's a feature
that we as a research team have not
spent any time looking at yet and are
very concerned about sort of how do you
do garbage collection garbage collection
on the scale of thousands or tens of
thousands of processors and even more
threads for me personally it's a big
concern it's also not my background so I
feel really woefully unprepared to sort
of tackle a problem but that's sort of
how we would imagine dealing with that
kind of problem I suspect there are a
lot of easy cases where you could
statically determine okay you know this
is a big array of objects and there are
no references captor to it and therefore
you don't really have much of a problem
but as you say as soon as you've
captured a reference to one of the
elements in those in that array you've
potentially created this really hard
problem to solve I don't have a really
good answer there I'm hoping we have a
parallel garbage collection good thing
to talk about later okay right
all right the fourth team of the
language is this notion of generic
programming and latent types so the
ability to sort of write code that is
more flexible in terms of type than what
we're used to and see for example we
have a number of ways of doing this the
first example I have here is a stat
class where the first thing I've
declared in it is a type T this sort of
says well there's some type T that's
used to parametrize this class I'm not
going to specify what it is here you can
think of this is a lot like a C++
template for example and then I can use
that type T to do things like allocate
data within the class or specify what
its methods return things like that we
also have this notion of sort of what I
call a type query variable if I write a
function like copy n elements takes in a
data array whose domain I don't really
know and don't really care about but
let's call it D for the purpose of this
function and that data is stored within
that array is again a type I don't
really know let's call it t though and
then I can use those identifiers later
on so I can say well this function
returns an array of over domain D also
of type T I can use them to declare
local variables things like that this is
a little bit sugary it's very similar to
these type variables of course but I
think it's really nice from a
Productivity standpoint and last example
is in many cases you can just write your
code sort of leaving the types off all
together they'll typically be inferred
in the case of this parameter from call
sites in the case of this variable from
the initializer that's signed into it
and so here the idea is you want to be
able to write code and leave off types
as people are used to in scripting
languages I should say that all of these
concepts you shouldn't think of as
resulting in a lot of runtime dynamic
checks and dispatch and things like that
most of these are more in sort of the do
analysis at compile time stamp out
multiple copies of it use the right copy
for each call site so it's more
convenience for the programmer to just
not have to write code multiple times
themselves but it doesn't result in a
lot of dynamic overhead police that's
the goal
this is a laundry list of other chapel
features we have notions of two poles
and type selects that's sort of a safe
way of switching over type we have
sequences and user-defined iterators we
have notion of reductions and scans
which are parallel prefix operators in
the language including the ability for
the user write their own reductions and
scans sars function calls go we have
notions of default arguments name based
argument passing we've overloading of
functions and operators currying a
function calls web notional module for a
sort of large code name space management
interoperability of how the languages is
a key feature because there's a lot of
code out there that people don't want to
rewrite from scratch but you do want to
interface with it and as I mentioned
garbage collection okay so i think i
have a few more minutes so we'll go
through an example computation i
normally give my audience a choice here
which computation they want to see but
i'm going to guide your choice towards
the fast multiple method which is one of
my favorites so this is a code which i
became interested in because a previous
DARPA program which was very interested
in sort of data intense computation had
sort of identified this is a real
interesting computation so what I did
was download their implementation which
was a sequential c or Fortran
implementation I think and I started
wading through the code as well as the
documentation and I just couldn't figure
out at all what it was trying to do it
was really frustrating and then I found
out that the guy who wrote the code is a
Boeing engineer so I went over and
talked to him we drew some pictures on
the whiteboard and I came away saying oh
this is really easy it's just that
seeing for trying to really bad
languages for expressing it so I'm going
to walk you through at least a little
bit of this what i'm doing here is
declaring two up sorry I'm terrible with
pointers declaring two arrays here outer
signature function in your signature
function and these are sort of these
arrays of arrays of arrays of arrays of
complexes all right so let me walk you
through what each of these arrays is the
first one is this levels are right
because
sorry what is the fast multiple method
trying to do the way Boeing uses it is
essentially to figure out sort of radar
signatures of plans i believe it's sort
of you can think of it as like an n body
style algorithm where you want to say
what are the impact of these components
on one another and things do drop off in
space as they do in sort of galaxies
simulations and such and that's sort of
about the extent of my knowledge of it
you want to say something more burn I
mean if it first appeared in those kinds
of problems and end body problems like
gravitation or whatever whereas the
usual barns that sort of approach says
if it's nearby all taken into account
it's far away land who are in something
like that but this says is well
depending how far it is away I'll
represented by a point or buy something
more fancy like a dipole or a quadrupole
or whatever so essentially what you do
is you take whole neighborhoods and
represent them in terms of what are
called multiple expansions of those
things which tell you sort of what
they're attractive repulsive you know
makeup is at sort of medium range this
is technology that is actually the
fastest technology available for solving
those problems and the best end body
codes there are combinations of Barnes
hut type thing and this technology
Boeing applied for the first time I
think although they didn't do the
research but they were the first people
to write the codes are you gonna be a
Velde company explain tour as I go and
give this part of it
whatever it's always helpful to Hepburn
in the audience okay so we've got this
big array of array of arrays race thing
this first one is the a 1d array just
over the levels of the hierarchy so I
have sort of the finest level in the
coarsest level and levels in between and
you notice that I'm using this level in
levels notation here which is if you
remember my for all expression and the
reason I do that is because I'm going to
use that level value sort of what level
are we currently out as a
parameterization for my other arrays
okay the next the next level the next
array is essentially a set of 3d arrays
of sparse elements per level so for
example all of these white elements here
are maybe this is my pentagonal plane
are all of the elements that are present
at the finest level at the course level
maybe I have all of the elements present
and because the elements that are
present at each level are a function of
that level that's why I make this
basically a function of the level of the
hierarchy we're currently on now each of
those elements is another array it's a
2d discretization of a spherical
function and the disk rotation varies
with level so at the finer levels of
hierarchy you can use a coarser
discritization at the course level
hierarchy you can use a finer
discretization so again because the
sizes of these 2d arrays are
parametrized by the level of hierarchy
again I'm that that domain is
parametrized by level and finally each
of those elements is a three element
vector where each of those values stored
there is a complex number ok so an array
of array array of rice but if you think
about the sincere Fortran well see in
particular it's all sort of a bunch of
one-dimensional arrays that are maybe
dynamically allocated and indexed into
sort of by hand in order to get all of
these different kinds of indexing and
it's just a complete mass you lose all
sort of notion of what's going on here
now I've obviously done a bunch of
declarations to get these different
domains levels sparse cubes signature
functions and so on those are sort of
more or less laid out here I'm not going
to walk through those in detail but it's
more or less the same concepts we've
been seeing and if it makes sense for
you guys I can give you a copy of slides
and you can look at us some more so
here's this computation which is done
this is sort of the hardest of the
different stages of the computation it's
called the outer to inner translation
and essentially what happens is each L
at any level in the hierarchy is
replaced by some function of their near
nearby neighbors in sort of a six by six
by six area and again I probably don't
have the time to walk you through this
in detail but the course structure here
is you can see I'm iterating over all my
levels from by negative one so from the
courses down to the finest and then at
each level I say for all cubes of that
level and then for all siblings in that
cube in that six by six by six region
compute this translation table which is
itself one of these large disk relations
of spherical functions of three element
things of complexes and then I say the
inter signature function plus equals the
outer signature function times the
translation table these are all large
element wise operations taking place
over these two-dimensional tables of
three area vector zuv complex numbers
okay so this is the way sort of these
computations end up looking in chapel
and one of the really nice things was I
took us back to the Boeing engineer and
I said well here's how I'd write this in
this language we're thinking about
working on and he sort of looked at and
he kept going hmm and I was like oh you
know you know this is a domain these are
these arrays these different things and
basically he kept saying well you've got
a bug here you really should be doing an
additional outer inner at the top level
the hierarchy or you know this should
really be looking at these siblings and
he was actually debugging my code as
opposed to trying to learn the language
and that to me was a really good sign
that sort of we'd come out something it
was at least more descriptive than sort
of Fortran C which I guess isn't that
part of a topic that target but it was
night is nice feedback to gap so let me
skip ahead now to just some concluding
stuff a lot of challenges and what we're
doing here big one is user acceptance
this is obviously true of any new
language and the HPC audiences
especially skeptical about new languages
having been burnt by high-performance
Fortran however I think that the
language we currently have are
inadequate therefore I don't think we
can let us let this stop us we want to
be able to implement this on sort of
commodity architectures not just on the
Cascade architecture but also on
clusters and things like that and I
think this represents a lot of
challenges we've designed language very
much with sort of our idealized cascade
architecture in mind clusters are not
ideal in many respects they don't have
sort of shared global address space
cheap single sided communication
normally but those are kind of things
you'd want for this language so we have
a lot of implementation and performance
challenges there I think even the
Cascade challenge implantation has a lot
of challenges these user defined data
distributions I think are going to be
really hard to get efficient a lot of
these language features we've chosen
sort of the the type determination of
latent with variables whose types
haven't been declared combined with
object-oriented with overloading just
sort of don't always play together in a
really nice way parallel garbage
collection I mentioned before is
something I worry about and and many
many others so what's next as I said
phase 2 of this H PCF program ends this
coming summer so what's next is phase
three proposals will be going in the
spring and it's expected that one or two
vendors will be funded to go on to phase
3 and phase 3 lasts from something like
july two thousand six to december two
thousand ten an interesting recent
occurrence though is that this language
effort chapel x10 from IBM and fortress
from sun has actually been sort of
forked off from the main part of the
program here DARPA's basically said well
this language stuff is really
interesting and it's too soon to sort of
kick anybody out of that those
explorations and so they've essentially
said that all three phase two vendors
can go on into phase 3 and continue this
language work at least for a year and a
half or so so they set up this team the
high productivity language systems team
which has a bunch of language people
from labs and academia to study and
evaluate these languages and and report
back to DARPA with their their their
decisions their findings this will
happen in sort of the from now to the
december two thousand seven timeframe
and what DARPA hopes will come out of
this is a language consortium effort
where it's not just sort of the Cray
language or the IBM language but a
language that the community as a whole
can get behind and not only the HPC or
traditional HPC community but also
trying to involve more mainstream
vendors so there's sort of this question
on everyone's mind of well multi-core is
coming and how are we going to program
that and is there overlap between these
goals so DARPA's is sort of at this
point cautiously optimistic that after
december two thousand seven there may be
this consortium effort that not only
involves the craze of the world but also
sort of the Microsoft's and Intel's
AMD's and things like that that's one of
the reasons I'm here today from my
perspective anyway you might have other
reasons
also helps to avoid repeating the
mistakes of the past so Aida and hpf are
sort of examples of government dictated
languages which never really caught on
they obviously would like this to
succeed so I've been talking to here
today but this represents the work of
many people both at cray and our
academic partners at Caltech JPL so I
just wanted to call them out and to
summarize we're designed Chapel to
enhance programmer productivity and to
address a wide range of workflows as I
described to you today we have sort of
these four themes in language that
motivate a lot of the features in
language on the status is we have this
rough draft language specification
available at a website that's being
hosted by the University of Washington
you're welcome to download it and read
through it it's better in some places
than others element we're still working
on revising it we're also working on an
open source implementation which is
coming along and we're interested in
feedback from users and and language
people and people like yourself so
that's all I have I can take any other
questions if there are any five minutes
with your questions and then like to
wrap up have some additional time on
bread scheduled this afternoon so people
want to be with them
what hours I'll talk to you now
otherwise it'll take time so que su did
it huh this one in the MTA you guys had
a programming model where you supposedly
try to avoid care about locality
forevers here you reintroduced it is
that because of some epiphany around the
the Terra model of programming or was
hardware driven sulfur trippin kind of
wet what made this is changing that's a
big question and I haven't been a crazy
long enough that I can give a very
detailed answer that but I can tell you
that the Cray architectural line has
been evolving away from this sort of
locality oblivious model to
architectures where locality sort of
matters more and more this is true both
on the vector and on the multi threading
sides of the company so I actually
haven't been involved in the hardware
architecture discussions which led to
those sort of decisions so I can't
really speak to why that's or the way
it's evolving but I think there's a
realization that when you have locality
it's nice to take advantage of it can be
advantageous and so to the extent that
architectures tend to be built that way
it makes sense to take advantage of it
and from our point of view if the
architecture is built that way the
program model should also be able to
take down
brief summary of what the statuses of
the implementation
yeah be really at the foulest the
implication is behind where I would like
it to be that's the that's the status
our first goal was to basically create a
just a sequential implementation asst
that would run on your desktop so you
could play around with things like these
domains and arrays and sort of the more
novel concepts language without having a
parallel machine or running multiple
processes also just to give ourselves an
easier target to shoot for and we still
don't have sort of a complete sequential
reference implementation yet what's
really happened I believe is that as I
mentioned a slider two ago the
interaction between some of these
features like the function overloading
and the type inference and object
orientation things like that really
ended up bogging down our influent a
shin efforts much more than we had
anticipated and this may have been just
due to the different philosophies that
people who are involved or just sort of
the inexperienced and for some of us
like myself in doing sort of these type
inference style work so we're kind of
behind where we wanted to be but it's
actually we've got this sort of critical
mass going now where things seem to be
added more and more quickly
what can you run now is why you just
describe your front issues from my
perspective this compadre that sounds
nice but you know what I really hear
what see what you brought right so our
compiler architecture second source
source code methodology so most of the
issues that you probably care about are
going to be front-end issues in the way
that we're approaching it and what can
you actually run you can run some simple
array and domain codes of sort of two
dimensions a lot of the more fancy kinds
of domains that we talked about here are
not in there yet there's a fair amount
of type type inference built into it I
don't know really how to characterize
what you can and cannot run are being
the main thing we're driving on is
trying to get these domains and arrays
sort of these more exotic flavors sort
up and running but to do it in a way
that uses the language features like the
type inference and overloading and
objects and things like that and so
therefore that's why a lot of our effort
is going into service more foundational
infrastructure type of work so from
there we would go to a parallel
implementation it looks like our short
term implication will target sort of
clusters and so their questions there
about what you use for sort of the
multithreading layer what's used for the
single-sided communication layer we're
looking in currently we have somebody
looking into sort of gas net and air mci
which are two single sided communication
layers for sort of commodity cluster
systems see whether either of those will
be rich enough to build on top of if not
we'll use something lower level or maybe
and Iowa we're trying to avoid
so you won't know
your cloths covers
what he's several years from now
possibly yes that's it that's a good
question so it was something like that
didn't fit into my pack the reason we're
optimistic Oh is is due to things like
ZPL which is built on as well as hpf
which is filter so this is results from
my decision in zg alfred it these are
some code size comparisons between unnie
in each case mpi code and left and ZPL
cut on the right and the main thing to
see here is that the CPL codes tend to
be a similar or a significantly smaller
in size with mg being a nice stand out
this is source code yeah and so the idea
here is that you can rights through the
compact language that performs well and
these are some speed up charts so higher
is better the x-axis this number of
processors the y-axis is speed up the
MPI is in blue and the CPL is in green
or yellow depending on the version and
again the point here is to show that we
can be really competitive with mpi which
sort of state-of-the-art in terms of
performance right now and we're
optimistic that we'll be able to take
these results and carry on this works
sort of in the context of chapel rice
had some results for HP f which were
kind of similar to this in p pop last
year and so h perhaps another influencer
of chapel and so again we sort of hope
to build on what they've done now at the
same time chapel is neither zpl RHP f we
have a lot of other features and so
there's this question of well can you
have these other features without losing
these performance management that
remains to be seen and unfortunately
yeah probably won't be for another year
any other questions
that
I Drive for his talk and it was very
interesting and if people would like to
meet with Brad later on today I'll just
please come up protector
there's this okay thanks